you know why they also can't say
anything true because DeSantis isn't
giving them what they want he is
responding to these clowns perfectly
which is basically by not responding at
all
house and schools emptied in response to
Florida's new guidelines on books I'm
wondering is this what actually you know
that video that was a fake narrative
that was not true and our press guys
where is Brian back there he can get you
the details on that uh this is trying to
create some narrative as if that they
hadn't even put the books out yet to
begin with so there's no need for all of
that stuff what they're trying to do is
they're trying to act like somehow you
know we don't want books the in some of
the narratives that you hear you hear
people talk about felony charges
understand nothing that we've done since
I've been Governor has done anything
that now there is long-standing Florida
law that prohibits an adult from giving
a school child pornography but don't we
think that that's inappropriate to do
but that's been the law for a long time
so when they hear you when you when they
start chirping about that understand
they're talking about long-standing
Florida law that's trying to protect
young children so I think they're trying
to do things to to Virtue signal I think
it's all politically motivated but what
the Department of Education I've asked
them I said talk to these school
districts tell are there books that that
are problematic are you really removing
and make them justify what they're doing
because I can tell you with our
curriculum transparency parents are
concerned if you have in sixth grade the
ability to access a book that has
pornographic acts depicted and you have
seen that across the country go read
books like genderqueer and see what's in
there it's inappropriate so we've armed
parents the ability to to object to that
and to make sure that they're having
education and not indoctrination but
anytime you hear about something that
seems so outlandish just understand
they're manufacturing that to try to
create a narrative that is the thing
you hear this and it is a manufactured
narrative do you think I would sit here
and defend this guy or defend the state
if they were really coming after books
really coming after books but we all
know that in essence you should not be
giving kids porn at a public school you
shouldn't be giving kids porn how about
that how about that it's just a blanket
statement but this is what the left
wants and they are all running cover
[Music]
foreign